Some of the posts on which I
have photos along with them,
we want to cache those too.
At the moment we're only caching
resources at install time.
Whereas appear over the lifetime
of the app with the posts.
So we want to cache
photos as they appear.
We could put these photos in IDB
along with the rest of the post data.
But that means we need to
read the pixel data and
convert it into a blob
that's kind of complicated.
It also loses streaming,
which has a performance impact.
When we get an item from a database,
we have to take the whole thing out in
one lump, then convert it into image
data, then add it to the page.
Whereas if we get the image from
a cache, it will stream the data.
So we don't need to wait for the whole
thing before we display anything.
This is more memory efficient and
leads to faster renders, even if
the data is coming from the disk.
For that reason,
the cache API is a much better fit.
But since we're into the advanced
stages of the course,
I haven't made this
totally straightforward.
Here's the code for the image,
it's a responsive image,
because images can appear at
a variety of different widths,
this responsive image let's the browser
decide which image to load
based on the width of the window and
also the network conditions.
So when the post error arrives
through the web socket,
which version do we cache?
Well we wait until the browser
makes the request.
Then we hear about it
in the service worker.
We go to the network for
the image and once we get a response,
we put it in the cache.
But the same time we
send it on to the page.
Note that we put the image into
a separate cache to the rest of
the static content.
We reset the content of our static cache
whenever we update our JavaScript or
CSS, but we want these photos to
live between versions of our app.
Next time we get a request for
an image that we already have cached,
we simply return it.
But here's the trick,
we'll return image from the cache
even if the browser requests
a different size of the same image.
Post on are short lived, so if
the browser requests a bigger version of
the same image returning a smaller one
from the cache isn't really a problem.
Returning a bigger image then
the one the browns asked for
that's perfectly fine too We're not
wasting bandwidth by doing that.
In fact, getting a smaller version
of something we already have cached,
that would be a waste of bandwidth.
Also this resizing windows back and
forth, it's only really
something web developers do.
We've covered most of the APIs you
need to be able to cache images,
there's only one thing left to cover.
You can only use the body of a response,
once.
As in, if you read the responses json,
you cannot then read it as a blob, this
is because the original data has gone,
keeping it in memory would be a waste.
Also respondWith uses the body
of the response as well.
So you cannot later read it again.
In most cases, this is great because if
the response was like a free gigabyte
video going to a video
element on the page,
the browser doesn't need to keep
the whole free gigabytes in memory.
It only needs to keep the bit,
it's currently playing plus
a little bit extra for buffering.
However, this is a problem for
our photos, we want to open a cache,
fetch from the network, and
send the response to both the cache and
back to the browser.
Using the body twice
like this doesn't work.
But we can fix this by cloning
the response we send to the cache.
So now a clone goes to the cache, and
the original gets sent back to the page.
The browser keeps enough of
the original request around to satisfy
all of the clones.